Could Barbie ever have been uncontroversial?
I don't think so
Because for the past fifty years, femininity has been a contested space
In the past, dolls had all been baby dolls
They had all been about teaching little girls how to nurture
Barbie was a wildly revolutionary toy
Barbie became things that real women hadn't become
She had broken barriers
These dolls enable girls to tell stories about dreams
She's been around 55 years, but the last few years have been trying for Barbie
Barbie was everything we didn't want to be...
...and were being told to be
Some people think Barbie needs to be liberated
You look at television and film and music...
... and you see the same body type being idealized
Perception of Barbie is that she's vapid, materialistic...
...and she's not healthy for girls
This limited understanding of who girls are is not acceptable
We have to make such a drastic shift, to get people to care about Barbie
The overall problem is being judged by our outsides, not our insides
It starts with just changing the ideals that we set forward as what a normal body looks like
Feminism, and how a girl sees herself, and self-esteem for girls
To put that all on the tiny plastic shoulders of a doll is quite a burden
I don't think I've ever been involved with something as culturally significant as this
We're taking a really big step forward
I don't want Barbie to be history